in 2015
43 million consumers worldwide were
victims of fraudulent car emissions
claims American car owners launched a
collective redress lawsuit against the
car maker Europeans however found it
near impossible because legislation in
EU countries was not always compatible
which are still pending in courts but
what about all the other European
countries first the European Union has
some of the most robust consumer
protection rules in the world Parliament
has reached an initial agreement with
the you governments to give European
citizens from across all Member States
the possibility to sue companies
collectively douzo douzo we do meet the
consumer to know something European the
red that you see they have a loom on
view cottagey it's a polytope possible
sound gasps Sam song Lyon kilometre once
the new legislation comes into force
consumer rights groups will be able to
take legal action on behalf of domestic
and cross-border victims of the same
rights infringement Loserville ve
escucho o Sanderlin european law - the
class action permit sir - the military
perimeter mizzu see that show here as
security to LEDs ultra prism through the
loser pays principle where the losing
party pays all the legal costs
Parliament's has ensured companies are
protected from a Beautif claims
you
[Music]